democrats in washington are clashing
over student loan forgiveness
after president biden said he would not
issue an executive order
for giving 50 000 in student loans
yeah party leaders are strongly asking
president biden to reconsider
and they're not the only ones with a
message for president biden a lot of
young people are upset
apparently even my assistant sonum
obsession
has something she would like to say sona
thanks conan
by the way sona i didn't know that you
were that political i'm not
but as someone who had a lot of student
loan debt i really wanted to weigh in on
this
terrific you have the floor go ahead and
urge president biden
not to forgive student loans wait a
minute
you don't want him to forgive student
loans
that's what i just said you see if i
didn't have crippling debt coming out of
college
i might not have been forced to take
this job as your assistant
which i have spent all of my formative
years doing
yeah that's true without student loans i
might have been able to pursue one of my
real passions
like documentary filmmaking instead i'm
here spreading hummus on a gluten-free
tortilla
just the way you like it not too much
hummus okay it's a really strong flavor
yeah thin layer by now i might have been
able to direct an award-winning film
about a girls school in afghanistan
but instead i'm driving around the city
looking for a chest merkin that matches
your hair color in case you decide to
wear a v-neck
it's important the hairs show do they
have one for down below
come on sona you have to admit the job
does have its perks you get to be on a
hit podcast you get to
appear on national television i love
being famous enough to be on the walls
of dry cleaners in glendale
and have grown men raiding my feet on
wiki feet
4.6 that's a pretty good rating
oh god in fact i love it so much
that i want to give this opportunity to
other students too
so please president biden don't cancel
student debt and allow
students to pursue their dreams make
sure they're desperate enough to take
any assistant job that comes their way
then one of them will have to take over
this job for me and i can finally do
something i enjoy
thanks yeah thank you sona by the way
you're fired
i wish
all right well listen we've got a uh
great show
tonight wanda sykes gonna be joining us
we'll take a break
we'll be right back terrific job sona
make sure do they have that for the low
back too i've got a little tuft there
that needs replacing
what's wrong with you it's true it's so
orange